[Music]
[Music]
house of the dragon is the upcoming game
of thrones prequel series based on
georgia or martin's fire and blood
a history of house targaryen set 300
years before the events in game of
thrones
the show begins filming in january 2021
and will air sometime in 2022
most likely in april set 300 years
before the events of game of thrones
the series tells a story of a turbulent
period for house targaryen
one that set sibling against a sibling
and dragon against the dragon
the point of contention who should rule
on the iron throne of course
if you'd like to know a bit more of what
the show will be about well i cannot
actually spill those beans
martin teased in his blog but you might
want to pick up a copy of two ontologies
i did with garner de zoice dangerous
women in rogues
and then move on to archmaester
gildane's history firing blood
dangerous swimming includes what press
materials describe as a 35 thousand word
novella
by martin cole the princess and the
queen or the blacks and the greens
which is about the dance of the dragons
the vast civil war that thor westeros
apart
nearly two centuries before the events
of game of thrones
the greens for the faction during the
dance of the dragons that supported the
claim of aegon the second targaryen
the rivals being the blacks who
supported the claim of her nehra
targaryen
both were named for the color of their
clothes born during one tourney
rogues meanwhile includes modern story
the rogue prince or a king's brother
which chronicles their early life
adventures misdeeds
and marriages of prince daemon targaryen
considered one of the biggest rogues in
the entire history of ice and fire
finally the novel fire and blood
released in november 2018
is the first novel of a two-part history
of the targaryens in westeros
centuries before the events of a game of
thrones house targaryen
the only family of dragonlords to
survive the doom of valyria took a
presidence on dragonstone
according to the book's description on
the author's site fire and blood begins
their tail with the legendary egg and
the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
in addition to this few casting calls
have been known
i'm speaking of that of daemon targaryen
the rogue prince
confirming that the house of the dragon
will be about the dance of the dragons
the targaryen civil war miguel
sapochnick and ryan condell will serve
as showrunners and executive producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
this summer it was reported that hbo has
released a casting call for george
armon's favorite targaryen
daemon targaryen a key figure from this
time period of the dance
of the dragons but who really is this
george r martin's favorite targaryen
and how big his role will be in the
upcoming game of thrones sequel
damon targaryen also known as prince of
the city lord flee bottom and the rogue
prince had many titles throughout his
life
prince sir commander of the city watch
master of coin master of loss
king of the stepstones and the narrow
sea protector of the realm
daemon was the most controversial man of
his lifetime
an audacious rogue prince and adventurer
who seemed made of good and evil in
equal measure
there was never a man so loved and so
reviled and at the same time as he was
during the dance of the dragons as the
husband of his niece rhaenyra he
supported his wife's claim
and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in westeros
he was rhaenyra's second husband
following sir leonard valorian
and she was his third wife prince damon
was the most experienced warrior of his
time
and wielded the valyrian steel blade
dark sister a dragon rider whose dragon
was characters daemon declared himself
the king of the stepstones and the
narrow sea
daemon was a skilled warrior described
in the histories as dashing daring and
dangerous
he was also ambitious impetuous
mercurial immoral reckless
and quick to take offense he is
described as being as charming as he was
hot
tempered starting from the very
beginning daemon was born as the second
son of prince balon targaryen
and his sister wife princess elisa
targaryen
in 81ac during the reign of his
grandfather
king jahiri's first targaryen he had one
older brother viserys
as well as one younger brother aegon
since his youth
damon's face was familiar to every cut
purse every lady of the night
and every gambler in flee bottom he was
knighted at 16
and king jahiri's first targaryen gave
him dark's sister for his martial skill
and prowess
demon's first marriage was to lady ria
royce
but he disliked both her and the veil of
aaron during the great council of 101 ac
daemon supported the claim of prince
viserys as it would make daemon and
heir after his brother daemon gathered a
small army when he was rumored that lord
corliss valerian was preparing a fleet
to defend the rights of his son
lena valerian whose mother was reignis
targaryen
they would later become closest allies
demonstrate briefly as master of coin
from 103 ac
until 104 ac and master of loss for six
months after that
governance board daemon daemon was
appointed commander of the city watch of
king's landing
daemon inspired loyalty with many of the
rank and file men of the city watch
improving their armaments and equipment
he gave every man a golden cloak
which led to the guards becoming known
as the gold cloaks
daemon developed a dark reputation for
the harsh punishments
he became acquainted with the lady of
the knight named mizeria
who would serve as his mistress of
whisperers in the streets of flee bottom
while daemon called himself the prince
of the city he became known as lord flee
bottom
among the residents of king's landing
daemon considered himself his brother's
heir
as viserys had no living sons and he
coveted
the title prince of dragonstone which
the king refused to grant
viserys's first wife emma arin died
birthing balon targaryen
viserys's second son the first having
died in the cradle
balon died a day after his birth however
daemon was observed in the street of
silk
making drunken jokes about the air for a
day
when the word of this reached the
grieving viserys the enraged king had
renera his daughter in daemon's niece
and future wife declared
heir in response to his ungrateful
brother's apathy
daemon left the capital in fury on
dragonstone daemon impregnated his lover
miseria
he wanted to present her with a dragon
egg the angry wizards demanded that
daemon returns the egg
and that he returns to his wife in the
veil daemon said miseria too less
but mazaria's ship sailed through a
storm in the narrow sea and miseria lost
the child
this hardened daemon against his brother
in 106
ac daemon led an army to invade the
stepped stones in the southern narrow
sea
with the support of lord corliss
velaryon and his fleet
and with the use of daemon's dragon
characters after conquering all but two
of the islands
daemon declared himself the king of the
stepstones and an
air of scene 109 ac being crowned by
coralie's the sea snake
bored with ruling his meager kingdom
daemon returned to the capital king's
landing in 111 ac
during the tourney that gave the greens
and the blacks their names
he reconciled with visery's first
targaryen by offering him his stepstones
crown
viserys welcomed his brother's return
and daemon was given a seat on the small
council
neither age or exile had changed
daemon's nature however
daemon was called with viserys's second
wife queen ellis sent high tower
and her children who had pushed him
further down in the line of succession
daemon spent hours in the company of his
niece princess rhaenyra targaryen
praising her beauty enthralling her with
tales of his adventures
giving her gifts and mocking her
stepmother and her greens
six months after his return it was
rumored that daemon took renera's
virginity
prior to her 16th name day and daemon
was exiled again
demon returned to bloodstone in the
stepstones and resumed his struggle over
his
bearing kingdom daemon's wife rhear
royce died from falling from horse in
115 ac
daemon departed to the veil of aryan to
claim runestone
which had been rhea's seat but he was
refused by house royce
not welcoming the veil daemon turned to
a drift mark
where he laid eyes upon the enchanting
lane of valerian
the beautiful daughter of his friend
lord corliss after killing inaudible's
betrothed
the son of the sea lord of braavos
daemon asked the sea snake for his
daughter's hand
because the marriage had been without
consent of king viserys first targaryen
damon and lena left westeros abandoned
the stepstones
and toured the free cities they remained
in pantos for some time when they
learned that lena was pregnant
causing their daughters bayla and reina
to be born there in 116 ac
daemon wrote his brother begging leave
to present his daughters to court
to receive a royal blessing the small
council advised the king to refuse
but viserys replied the daemon is a
father now he will have changed
after giving his two daughters daemon's
second wife lena died in 120 ac
trying to birth him a son who died as
well in 120 ac daemon married again
this time to his niece princess rhaenyra
targaryen
this marriage was performed suddenly
without the knowledge of king viserys
the first targaryen
and was scandalous since neither lena
nor lane or velaryon
daemon's previous wife and rynera's
previous husband had been dead for six
months
according to mushroom it was daemon who
arranged the death of lenore
by paying sir corey to kill him thus
making rhaenyra available to mary
daemon and rhaenyra had two sons
together prince aegon the younger born
in 120 ac
and prince visery is born in 122 ac
while viserys the first targaryen had
decreed rhaenyra targaryen his heir
sir kristen cole crowned queen allison
hightower's son aegon ii targaryen
after viserys's death in 129 ac
the greens took advantage of being in
king's landing at a time of the death of
king viserys sentok the throne
while most of the blacks were at
dragonstone at the start of the civil
war called the dance of the dragons
prince daemon had more experience in
warfare
than all their foes combined during
rhaenyra's rival coronation on
dragonstone daemon plays the crown of
king jahiri's first targaryen on the
head of his wife
proclaiming her the queen and claiming
himself the protector of the realm
daemon led the assault on harrenhal
capturing the ruined castle from its
castellan
after hearing of the death of his
stepson prince lucerus valerian at the
hands of his nephew
prince eamonn targaryen daemon through
his spymaster and former mistress
maiseria
hired blood and cheese to kill a son of
fake on the second
son for a son daemon abandoned harrenhal
when eamon and kristen begin marching
on the great castle with a host of
greens instead
daemon flew characters back to king's
landing and assisted rhaenyra with
capturing the city
he made his niece and wife rhaenyra the
queen of the seven kingdoms
while searching for aemond and vegard
who were burning the riverlands
daemon took dragon seed nettles for a
bed mate and made their base in maiden
pool
maester norin informed daemon that queen
rhaenyra wanted nettles dead
because some dragon seeds betrayed her
daemon thanked the maester for the
warning
and he and nettles separated the next
morning daemon challenged the aemond
waiting for 13 days at harrenhal until
eamon
stopped burning the riverlands to come
to face him on the 14th
day just as damon was about to slash a
14th mark at the heart tree in godswood
to mark each passing day
a shadow swept over the castle vegar had
come at last
and on her back road one-eyed prince
eamonn he had not come alone
pregnant with his child alice rivers
flew with him
alice helped eamonn find daemon as she
saw him in the fire
the prince helped this woman down from
vegard's back
then turned to face his uncle calling
him a fool for coming to face him alone
because his dragon is the oldest
and the most powerful dragon on which
daemon replied were i not alone you
would not have come
finally eamon says to him you have lived
too long and daemon replies on that much
we agree
before climbing their dragons when he
climbed upon characters daemon did not
fast in his chains that connected him
since daemon's dragon was a lot younger
and smaller than eamon's
daemon was quickly hidden in clouds
while eamonn looked for him
when characters attacked vugar she
ripped upon his stomach and tore one of
his wings
but then characters fast and his jaws
surround her throat in death grip
these injuries force them both to cease
flying
and as they tumbled through the water
below daemond dueled eamonn to death
as he never fast and his settle daemon
stood up on characters
and lapped at aymond whereupon he drove
his dark sister through eamonn's eye
and through his neck just a second
before hitting the water
the battle above the god's eye ended in
the deaths of both riders and both the
dragons
daemon was 49 when he died unlike
eamon's body however
demons was never found singers say that
damon lived to spend the rest of his
days in secret with nettles
but most historians disagree i actually
believe daemon did not die here
and i have a good theory about it which
i will post in the following days
demon never achieved his ambition to sit
on the iron throne
though his son sagan iii and viserys the
second eventually did
in conclusion house of the dragon is
coming daemon targaryen will be one of
the main characters and probably my
favorite
just like he is george r martin's
favorite over the centuries house
targaryen has produced both
great men and monsters prince damon was
both
in his day there was not a man so
admired so beloved
and so reviled in old westeros he was
made of light and darkness in equal
parts
to some he was a hero to others the
blackest of villains
this is a good description of daemon the
best description comes from george
r martin of course i'm notorious
for my love of grey characters and one
of the greatest characters in the entire
westeros is damon targaryen the rogue
prince
uh we we took one of the sidebars and
made a separate story out of it the
rogue prince
damon is the younger brother of king
viserys the first
for a time he was the heir to the throne
when viserys had no children
and then vasara started having children
and he stopped being the heir to the
throne he's a notorious bad boy
a rogue in every sense of the word uh he
was a rival
for the sarah's sister and his own niece
rhaenyra
and then later he became the husband of
rhaenyra he switches sides several times
you never know what side he's going to
come down on
he's a very colorful and unpredictable
character
and um i think he has to rank up there
as my favorite but the
the book is full of uh what i hope are
interesting characters
i honestly cannot wait for house of the
dragon let me know which side you're on
are you supporting the greens or the
blacks in the targaryen civil war
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did please give it a big thumbs up and i
hope to see you in the next one
peace
you